is affirmative action on The Chopping
Block the Supreme Court could finally
abolish the race-based practice that's
been screwing over High achieving Asian
American students for decades John Wang
is one of the people suing and claims
that affirmative action is to blame for
his recent rejection from Top tier
colleges and universities despite his
near perfect s.a.t scores
John Wang now telling a story to Laura
Ingram
in a new Fox Nation special
the top tier schools I applied to were
MIT Caltech Princeton Harvard Carnegie
Mellon and UC Berkeley guidance
counselors they all told me that it's
like tougher to get in like
um especially as an Asian American I
just took it as gospel I had a 20 chance
of gaining admission to Harvard as an
Asian American and then a 95 chance as
an African-American
so where does affirmative action stand
right now in in the court
affirmative action is still the law of
the land okay the problem is that we now
have a world of equity where there's no
real equality and when what he was
saying is he's got a 20 chance of
getting into Harvard if you're
African-American with those same numbers
you've got a 95 chance wow of getting in
I mean the Ted the scales are so tipped
against the qualified people in terms of
you know kind of what are we doing we're
trying to make up for whatever happened
in the past get over it and start all
over again it's taking away the
incentive of of people if you just did
it by scores only scores would you have
what a majority of Asian undergraduate
people can't just jump in because that's
what Harvard did uh they call it a fake
study whatever Harvard wrote down on a
piece of paper that if they were to do
that 43 of their student body would be
Asian Americans and they did they denied
that that's one of the key pieces of
evidence in this case that has worked
its way up through the Supreme Court I
think that that this supreme court I
think is going to do away with this WOW
unfortunately for students everywhere I
think that the schools are going to find
some sneaky way to get around it they'll
call it something else they'll say that
they're looking at other things however
I think these students are going to set
a precedent that's not only for colleges
but think about that school down Thomas
Jefferson High School down in Virginia
one of the one of the top schools this
is also an issue for for Asian Americans
at that school and those parents have
banded together and said we are not
going to allow this what I think will be
very interesting if this when the
Supreme Court decides this it will
happen at first at universities I think
then to the private schools and then
what happens in Corporate America
because it could be a real effect all
the way down Mr Greg Gutfeld oh he's
such a wang yo you know a guy got a 1590
and you should have taken it again
1600 buddy that's what I got actually
I'm kidding the reality is this guy is
obviously very smart and he might be too
smart for college you know get a job at
SpaceX don't waste your time it's
obvious when you develop quotas for some
people others are going to get elbowed
out and in this day and age Asians are
not getting a fair piece of the pie
anymore because the pie is finite it's
kind of interesting that you know
there's this we all talk about how
cultures are different and you better
not culturally appropriate but then we
apply the prism of equity on cultures
which are impossible because they're
different like every culture is
different you can't expect the same
outcome for this type of person and this
type of person and this type of person
sorry it's not true it won't happen Okay
uh but why would you want to go to a
place that doesn't want you there you
know take your brain elsewhere like
DeVry
or Stanford Stanford's like a poor man's
divide
okay
that's where you want to get in yes if
you were running one of these
universities what would your admissions
policy be based on
a whole host of issues and and one of
them is obviously grades I think that it
does make sense when you see you look at
the data on this Americans do generally
support wanting to promote diversity on
campuses but then where it gets tricky
is that they the majority opposes
explicit consideration of race so those
two things don't add up and that's why
you have States like California and
Michigan both not red states that have
banned affirmative action on the basis
of race I thought that was something
um interesting Gavin Newsom could
comment on more when this decision comes
down I'm I'm really looking forward to
seeing how Clarence Thomas And Justice
uh Sotomayor
talk about it because they both have
openly benefited they've talked about
getting race-based affirmative action
got them to Yale law school and Clarence
Thomas got a scholarship to Holy Cross
for college that was only for uh racial
based minorities and he's talked about
the benefits of that and that he's
sitting on the Supreme Court today
because of affirmative action and over
the years and people do evolve and this
happens to a lot of people he now
doesn't think that it's necessary
anymore so if you take your position
judge where you just say get over it and
I don't think that we can get over
slavery and the systemic challenges that
still face people of color in this
country but if that is the case that
he's going to make I think it will be
riveting to see that especially in
contrast to a colleague of his and
they're apparently very close friends
who feels differently about the benefits
of race-based affirmative action
did you go to DeVry University
no I went to Stanford oh I'm just
kidding I
did because I didn't have time I don't
listen what I'm saying hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else